friends and bachelor co-stars mourn the
loss of Lex McAllister in the wake of
the 31 year old bachelor contestants
death friends and former co-stars took
to social media to share memories and
their condolences
McAllister's former bachelor Jake
Pavelka took to Twitter Tuesday to share
his sadness whoa I'm so sad to hear
about Alexa my heart breaks for her
family covering them in prayer during
this rough time former co-star Tenley
moles on also sent her condolences
saying remembering Lex she was vibrant
prayers to her family Jessie since a k--
winner of Deana Pops's season and friend
of Lex posted this touching throwback
photo with the caption it saddens me
deeply to hear the news of my friend Lex
McAllister you will be missed until we
meet again dear rest in peace gone but
not forgotten the ABC bachelor family
also extended their condolences telling
et in the short time that we knew Lex
she was a lovely person inside and out
she will be missed by the entire
bachelor family and we extend our
heartfelt condolences to her family and
friends